i want to make it clear i understand
what assault is
i'm not in high school if i were in high
school like
we need help to beat sleepy joe biden i
don't think so we used to have a temper
nice
i don't have a temper anymore i don't
ever nothing ever bothers me
joe biden is a dummy look folks
i get it i call him one percent joe
no i'd rather run against i think biden
than anybody
i think he's the weakest mentally and i
like
running against people that are weak
mentally i think joe is the weakest up
here
[Music]
subject for today
[Music]
yeah i didn't get the best out of that
slurp because this is one of the mugs
when we had the uh the shortage from the
vox apocalypse
so remember we had to recruit separate
mug providers and the handle is a little
bit smaller
so it's less practical but it's limited
edition
oh that's a nice way to spin it for
everyone who has it
uh really glad to be with you we do have
that debate next tuesday night
if it actually happens and joe biden
shows up in person we'll see he will
never be so happy to eat my words
and he will swallow his tongue i don't
think that's part of dementia
i don't think it's a side effect of
levodopa so we're going to be talking
about a whole lot today hunter biden is
in some new hot water
new york portland uh mr bill barr has
deemed them anarchist jurisdictions uh
we'll have manny the art critic on
as well as uh tomorrow florida buying
the votes of felons but my happiness and
lawyer bill richmond is here
hey glad to be here glad to be here a
quarterback garage from your house hey
what's up
gerald day how are you i am well sir
good i'm doing okay and
uh rbg how are you no no no no
he's still on it stop it such a loving
dog he's all bone
just uh no good boy see he's he's
he's a god no he's not cause he just oh
don't go there no don't
wow that's not that she would have
wanted it that way so
what a woman he's really invested in my
program
will be in michigan state capitol yes
sing
on uh no one pet him one says hey joe
lewis go to your place
hey can someone come and grab a little
joe someone
in an edit bank grab joe lewis come for
the source
i got him i got him don't worry he's
he's no but it's going to distract me
because my dog
should not be eating the honorable ruth
bader
anyone really it's hard to focus
i don't think that dog eating is the
worst thing that's happening right now
uh all right before we move on let's
just hit this right at the top it's
breaking hunter biden finds himself in
more hot water you know about barisma
and you know about the fact that he did
the crack and was banging hookers
yeah oh wow and his brother's widow but
uh
there's some new developments because of
a senate
report uh i think fox news is the only
one to have covered it
uh hold on let's go to cnn really
quickly before we have there's the uh
uh um same-sex attracted brave hungarian
um that's a nice portrait but no so they
are not covering it i've watched them
all morning i haven't seen them cover
hunter biden doesn't mean they haven't
but i've watched at least two hours of
cnn
fox news covered it let me show you what
they covered
the senate homeland security and finance
committee finding the obama
administration
new hunter's position on the board in
2014 was
problematic ignored the glaring warning
signs
joe biden the committee also obtaining
records from the treasury department
showing quote
potential criminal activity in
transactions with hunter and his
associates with ukrainian
russian kazakh and chinese nationals joe
biden's campaign
on the probe exploit to bail out donald
trump's re-election campaign
yeah i think joe biden is doing like
he's doing like the katie holmes the
kind of house oh yeah
oh yeah the
yeah let me do it again i can do better
a little bit of jew barrymore that's
stealing your taxes so what do we know
that's new
what's new we have from the senate
report well we know about barisma and he
was obviously sitting there making six
figures uh monthly not yearly yet
actually because i don't know a lot of
you think of his salaries annualized but
he got 3.5 million dollars i want to
make sure i have this right from the
senate report
from the former the wife of the former
mayor of moscow ah
russian ties yeah and and chinese ties
too yeah
was he banging her too no but he did
allegedly use some of that money not
only for prostitutes
hunter biden it takes a special sack of
human [ __ ] to do what he did
it wasn't only prostitutes it was from
what we know this is from the senate
report
people who are victims of a sex
trafficking ring oh so hunter biden was
the guy behind the glass and
taking two oh well taking two or three
were there bidding i think it was two
i will beat on girl from lost
[Laughter]
i do uh liam neeson my gps is only four
blocks away i will bid on girlfriend
lost and cannot see how this situation
goes wrong
give the girl to men with teeth
[Laughter]
how awful hunter biden that is uh how is
this not being covered
anywhere this guy his dad is running for
president and his dad effectively got
him that
got him the job they're saying it's a
political hit piece though it's okay you
can just sweep it it's a
political hit piece for donald trump to
bring up the fact that i
used my power to get my son into a seven
figure contract with a company that he
had no business working with
as well as using the former mayor wife's
3.5 million dollars to
buy sex slave you know what i am so
tired the media keeps focusing on the
wrong
you know one cares about real news
anymore it's all about the kardashians
and miley cyrus and the vice president's
son
buying sex slaves i mean come on this
country coming too
i thought one of the interesting things
was it wasn't just that republicans had
been saying it
and that folks had been suspecting that
this was a big problem because we
already know about barisma generally
right but it was that obama officials
not only knew because we know they knew
but that they knew it was wrong yeah
right that's part of what's
kind of part of the report that's not
getting a lot of attention and it really
is only starting
being covered really in the last kind of
30 to 60 minutes you're getting a few a
few articles come out
but cnn still is oh is there any way for
us to like not mention
and let's be clear yeah this is from a
senate report so this is not something
that's being um
it's being argued right it's just how
unethical is it
yeah it's really the argument right now
exactly it's really
uh it probably wasn't illegal and how do
you
feel about uh the son of a sitting vice
president
right buying from let me get this right
make sure i have a quote from buying sex
slaves from an
eastern european trafficking ring how do
you feel about it that's eastern europe
you know what that's you can tell he has
a type oh like he's not going for the
voluptuous you know cover of stuff
magazine he likes that sort of like
bulgarian uh anorexic look ah
is it the tears that he wants probably
that's what it is
it's unwilling tears of a taxpayer tears
of
uh of sex slaves hunt it's just hunter
biden yeah well i
i thought it was tears of a a widow yeah
that too as well
no no you've probably been there think
about this this is a guy who probably
role played with his
his brother's widow that she was uh
an illegally uh sex trafficked slave an
eastern european
yeah that's required for him look it's
not like there's an eddie murphy or a
hugh
grant you know who just showed up i'm
like i'm lonely like
come on the guy used money from the
former and we're
talking about russian interference yeah
ten thousand dollars on three thousand
ads what
the guy used money for russia for sex
like come on
right and if the left is really
concerned about ties to russia and ties
to china and things that they have
really
no no he exactly he was going further
than that yeah
if they really are not if they really
are concerned about that they should be
just as concerned with his ties
right and joe biden's sons ties because
they've done everything they can to get
rid of donald trump jr
to get rid of you know jared kushner and
all of their ties which is terrible
is fair they're fair game because
they're public figures right but so is
hunter
exactly that's my point when you start
getting three million dollars for sex
slaves
i think you're uh valedictorian yeah
absolutely bill you made a great point
john kerry i think
under oath said that he had no idea what
was going on and they have documents now
that prove that he was briefed on it the
day after he was appointed to buriesma's
board well his head's a trapezoid so i
buy it
it's hard for information to stay in
there can't be captured it's a naturally
repellent
no i mean that is the part that is the
part that does
raise the questions and it does support
what the president has been saying about
the level of corruption
and the involvement again not just in
the obama administration again i'm not
saying that
you know obama was there he was like all
right is he on the board all right great
excellent no
it but that officials knew that it was
wrong and without a question
joe biden has not come out with an
explanation right and now it's clear
that he can't
so i am very excited whether he wanted
to or not now he's not unique
no it's not unique he can never come up
with an explanation sure he can't tell
you how his shoelaces are tied did they
do the rabbit ears or did they do that
around the world ah
i pooped but but this is why the timing
is so there's you know we're starting to
see some of these articles that are
coming out washington post et cetera
that are saying
well well you know this is clearly tied
to uh smearing joe biden
ahead of the debates but i will tell you
what it really is
is it gives less room for joe biden to
equivocate
on what was known or not known what he
nor didn't know
they're starting to box him in even
further about how bad the situation was
which is actually what the american
people need to know they need to be able
to not let joe equivocate on this they
need to hear the vice president go out
there and say yeah
i'm just gonna play dumb still no no i
am dumb it's not playing yeah
right sir we have that acting yeah we
have video of you saying you told him to
get rid of the prosecutor can we go to
the video
you said he's the simple jack of
politics
okay so can i ask you a quick question
okay it's a prediction question
is like at the town hall is trump going
to bring evidence in his pockets
i sure hope so he's just going to bring
a gun
like uh look what i found in hunter's
hotel room
edible panties gross gross
and that's the good point that what
you're talking about is just
equivocating because can you ima
think of this for a second they were
speculating going was donald trump jr on
cocaine when he was doing his uh his rnc
speech likely again
can you imagine if donald trump jr they
went after them for going on big game
hunts that by the way sustained the
entire economies
totally legal things in regions yeah
exactly can you imagine
if they were doing blow off an eastern
european sex slaves hip bones
oh yeah it would be you know it would be
every channel you know what the rich are
different
uh let me really quick so by the way if
you're watching this on the youtube do
subscribe uh on apple podcasts and
android this is the time to let you know
and uh leave a review or a star rating
there and uh every thursday and monday
there's a secret word in the podcast
and uh there are instructions on how to
win a lock of uh gerald a's hair
uh also of course do consider joining
mug club loudos credit.com club there's
a whole other like 45 minutes of the
show today
every day so much more content and it's
the only way this continues so uh my
other question of the day
here is well you know i you know what
the que how do people get away with this
honestly what does it take just kind of
like we're going to be talking about
federal jurisdictions right uh bill barr
saying these are anarchists
jurisdictions people
oh this is this is just uh playing
political football hold on hold on a
second
all right it sounds absurd on its
surface and granted i understand that me
referring to something as absurd when my
domesticated animal
just chewed uh a sitting corpse of ruth
bader ginsburg
i don't have a leg to stand in but i
don't need it it was a supreme line i
only need one leg
like a stork
i thought that should happen at chaz let
me explain to you my logic
how could billbar do this when jazz when
they say hey listen guys you can't be
shooting people in american cities and
uh burning down precincts
bad looks like a teenager in their
bedroom smoking cigarettes like in
face-off you know they're over there
chas was the over-the-top teen
caricature from a 90s
very much i'm going back to listening to
sublime man
so this was chad we're doing our own
thing like hey stop killing people stop
raping stop pooping intense screw you
we're gonna do our own thing man and
like all right well listen
hey may or mayor's excuse you we're
gonna let them do their own thing they
don't obey your laws man
at what point do you say oh you don't
obey the laws of the land you don't get
any money
from the land i don't i thought it
should happen with jazz it's a pretty
simple simple
process that they should go through and
they think that's fashionable oh fascist
just stop burning down your [ __ ] wait so
you hate us because you want our money
still
is that what i'm hearing it we'll get to
it so
bloomberg is buying votes in florida
there's so much to get to today that's
the biggest
uncovered story kyle written house is
being charged jake gardner the guy who
shot
uh skurlock there in uh uh was it uh
oklahoma oh yeah
okay we'll get it all right so my
question anyway okay
uh here's something else i just want to
cover really quickly because i've been
talking about this on cnn
you've heard this story of i think it's
uh olivia troy back to facebook
caster troy so nice too olivia
olivia troy uh you've heard this story
everywhere they go this pence aide
is turning on trump uh this pence this
pence hire is now
talking about here's a clip to give you
an idea where uh she's talking about
donald trump behind closed doors this is
the insider who's turned on the
administration
not quite but here's the clip they show
there are many possibilities
stop it quarterback dude
can you read a and b
a b c d e f fired fire
put this on me in spanish i don't care
that's a clip because mitt romney knows
that he's gonna support uh donald trump
he said he's gonna support donald
trump's supreme court pick sorry i
forgot a lot to get to today
guess what uh he's still a dick this
this is not redeeming him what kind of
dirk do you think someone had on him
for him to be like all right i'll go on
was it someone like hey uh mitt romney
this is uh
this is not a pic of you a picture of
you after uh temple last weekend with uh
a mug of maxwell house oh no
no yeah yeah well you'll be confirmed i
think you'll be confirming the supreme
court now
i won't wait up you think this special
underwear controversy was bad
it's decaf well it depends when jose
smith gets on his red telephone ring
ring ring it's uh now it's hot drinks
it's not so much caffeine
what about booze is now good i should
have confirmed gorsuch maybe he did
just hit the stones again and see oh no
it's you're right quarterback i missed
those i do have this
do we have the next clip okay this is
olivia troy the person you're supposed
to know as and this ties into
the hunter biden thing it's nothing but
hearsay
all of the scandals with donald trump
this is the new one they want you to
think that everyone is turning on donald
trump so hopefully you will these are
his closest insiders and mike pence
close insider
olivia troy talking about how horrible
they are behind closed doors did the
president of the united states really
say that
absolutely i was sitting to the right of
him in the room when he said it
and he was like and you know when you're
a politician you have to shake a lot of
hands
you have to shake a lot of hands and
these people are disgusting it's gross
and so maybe covet cope it's probably a
good thing right
i don't have to shake hands i don't have
to do that anymore he said that
maybe kova's a good thing because he
doesn't have to shake hands with
people disgusting people
that's what he said oh my god
by the way a sensibility well known
donald trump is a germaphobe
i think donald trump was a dick when i
was a kid because i happened to read an
esquire magazine it might have been rob
report i used to read these at
archambault in canada
on the newsstand and he talked about how
he hated social gatherings because he
didn't like shaking hands
does it mean that hot doesn't mean that
he thinks his voters are disgusting does
howie mendel think everyone on deal or
no duel
because he fist bumps it's well and this
was probably said in the context
of a joke most important olivia troy by
the way was not hired he wasn't
she wasn't hand-picked by mike she
worked in the bush and obama
administration she was a legacy hire
from the department of homeland security
she never liked donald trump and mike
pence this is all they have
oh russia well there's nothing there
donald trump called the troops losers
and suckers well we've confirmed that's
not true look at this new scandal can
you believe that he hates his own
supporters
no because she wasn't picked by donald
trump or mike pence she's a liar
and that's funny as [ __ ] so i don't care
just like when he said to uh remember
was
uh
uh sarah huckabee sanders yeah with kim
jong-un he said
oh i think this is the famous scandal he
said i think kim jong is taking a liking
to you
go take one for the team
[Laughter]
do you know how we know that story
because she told us
it yeah it was it's a joke this was
probably
they probably said hey it's like this
lady could have been a librarian like uh
we're going through the previous staff
do you want to keep the library uh
what's she doing what does she do shush
people who uses a library she's got a
nice little pooper on it too a job
yeah this troy gal seems like she'd be
able to take a joke real well yeah yeah
exactly and let's be honest
people are disgusting okay people are
discovered people are disgusting come on
maybe someone's gotta be real i'm not
going to lie when we have when we have
uh
we do the meet and greets after the show
i love meeting fans but every now and
then someone comes up
and it is pungent it is right it is
life and they're like and they're
coughing i don't know
and this is pre-coveted that you had
this yeah i i
i am not a hater of people but i am a
hater of uh touching a lot of people
are you saying code is a good thing
stephen yeah that's basically what i
just heard as well you know what
i'm neutral at this point
think about every major scandal this is
what there's that guy who does the what
the trump report every day it's like
let's list this so far donald trump is a
rapist no
no that's again people who've come out
and they've all been donald trump
colluded with russia no no we know
that's true
not true donald trump uh called the
troops losers and suckers
no no oh the former donald trump aide
said that he hates his supporters no
no that's what they have do you know
what the scandals are with hunter biden
receipts of 3.5 million from the wife of
the mayor of moscow
used for sex slaves
senate report yeah exactly it's got a
little bit more weight to it and by the
way she was actually
fired the lady was actually fired in
question she had nothing to lose
according
to bill crystal a famous never trumper
now right nothing to lose and
against going against the most powerful
world yeah exactly oh different guy i
think
bill crystal not billy crystal i don't
know which one it is
all right but nonetheless she was fired
a three-star a three-star general came
out and said
actually i was there in every one of
these meetings i never heard him say
anything like that
and i fired her and escorted her from
the building a three-star general versus
her yeah i'm not sure who i'm counting i
just heard escort
breaking news it's called the strategic
approach may cause
fatigue muscle pain cosmetics and
neurological symptoms
there are six guess what the federal
government
right the flu causes that yeah but
really quickly a very important thing
look at the long-haul thing they're
doing at the bottom that is the next
phase of the kova deal okay fine people
are getting over it but there are
long-haul consequences that we have to
you know that that is absolutely yeah
al experience and talks a lot about this
he's like just watch out for that
because we may get to a point where
these things go down and destroy down
hospitalizations but that's the phrase
that people are going to use to scare
you down
long haul and there may be long-term
consequences that's fine to deal with
that and figure out what it is
they don't know that that's with a lot
of diseases exactly i don't know if you
know this but it's really hard to test
for mono because
once you have it you always have it
right and there's a more expensive test
to do i found this out because i had it
and they were like my doctors well that
just test means that at some point i've
had it he's like this is a different
test that we have to do to find out if
it's active right but if you're really
tired
you know just go home and sleep okay
yeah but half of what they're saying
right now though is that it could cause
a heart arrhythmia well they could have
had that arrhythmia before
yeah right i think that's the right word
my wife will help at this point i don't
trust anybody you know she knows he's
better
i also don't trust the heart arrhythmia
because they put hunter biden in the
control group
of course i'm doing coke and banging on
him
unprotected that's not the old standard
he had secret service protection with
him during his time in mrs trump
you can't snort through the mask
the spit mask well i can but it's an n95
so by the time it gets it's almost as
though it's less potent
oh no activated charcoal my ass i have
to do more
all right uh here's another thing that
just really bothers me and i'm curious
as to half asian bill your thoughts on
this i'm looking forward to having manny
the art critic
behind the paywall because i'm so tired
of news
so let's talk about bloom bloomberg the
failed uh the failed pilot who ran for
uh the democratic really short guy
yeah yeah that guy the dancing the yeah
yeah
dancing barney uh by the way what
happened to people who were against
corporate money in elections
look how much joe biden is fundraising
unless it helps us
dinesh d'souza was put was put in cool
hand luke
mason ankle chain because he gave 5
dollars to a friend's senatorial camp
that she lost
yeah but it was because she lost right
wasn't that why he was historiated they
were like
gave to a loser they gave two yeah he's
like i didn't know
she was going to be a loser when i gave
the donation all right we're just gonna
house arrest you so you shut up
you're gonna go down for a crime at
least win pick a winner so anyway
man of the people billionaire uh and uh
attempted big gulp banner michael
bloomberg
uh he's paid fines for 32
000 felons in florida so that they can
vote
because there's a law in florida that
was passed in 2018 i would argue stupid
reinstating voting rights for felons
that dictated they could register only
if they pay all fines fees and
restitution
some uh sometimes totaling more than a
thousand dollars owed to
the government so uh i think there are
there's our carve-outs for specifically
only sexual assault and murder is what i
found so if you actually commit
like robbery or just normal assault like
assault regular
bloomberg can just pay assault zero
i think he wrote in he said as long as
it's not big gulp
right yeah okay yeah think about this
first so you
in florida let's let's let's walk
through this here
you can uh strong-arm a liquor store for
a pack of camels
or cools that's probably your pick you
can strong-arm a liquor store for a pack
of
cools and colt 45. you go to jail
you come out or you haven't served your
fine even paid your fine bloomberg
billionaire comes in because he wants to
buy your vote
pays your fine and then you get to vote
in for the government that establishes
laws
regarding armed assault well he can't
buy the presidency so he's got to buy
something he's got to buy something
buy it for somebody else i hope he
spends every dollar disregard the laws
why do you get to vote on the laws now i
understand the difference between a
non-violent offender
right we talked about this yesterday i
think that non-violent felons for
example
like i don't know if it's tax evasion or
let's say let's say even if it's theft i
don't know when theft becomes a felony
like
probably not stealing from a supermarket
based on the amount or the types
but let's say it's not violent you know
what i mean i don't think you should
lose your
your second amendment right once you've
served your debt to society however if
you have committed serious felonies that
are violations of laws that infringe on
other people's rights
i don't think that you should you should
vote on laws protecting people's rights
and keep in mind to in florida they're
neck and neck donald trump and uh
and biden and uh last time it was
separated
something like a few hundred dollars
yeah it was a tiny small amount of votes
fortunately right now biden actually
it's 45 41 i think
was the last one that i saw trump now
trump is actually yeah
well that's because fantastic we used to
wait for the cavalry you know showing up
around the hill now it's just you're
waiting for cubans
yeah well and why why does bloomberg
want to pay for this it's because he
knows that these felons are going to
vote for his guy
he hopes that he knows who hates felons
cubans
that's the mistake that the left has
made with with immigration with illegal
immigrants
they've just taken all spanish speaking
i think it was in miami-dade county
right two-thirds of the people who
responded in spanish which means it
probably
means they probably don't even speak
english right probably telemundo
they responded that they supported
donald trump and i think the big mistake
is people who are spanish
people who are legal immigrants they do
not want to be lumped in with illegal
immigrants and they don't want to be
single issue voters
in opening up the border and not
building a wall especially cuban
americans
that is a huge shift for florida because
cuban americans were the most
overwhelmingly republican voting bloc
and then they switched they broke for
obama for a while i think just
a lot of people did kind of like donald
trump obama wasn't unknown
he was charismatic so a lot of people
voted for him but now cuban americans
have broken overwhelmingly for donald
trump
and it's surprising i don't have these
numbers exactly but i kind of have to
piecemeal them
everyone who is from south america or
latino who is not mexican
is surprise is almost all inherently
conservative on individual issues yeah
and so there is a way a foothold there
that you can get but they might be
voting democrat the difference is of
course a lot of people from mexico
directly
have family members who are illegal
immigrants because of close proximity
people in chile
people uh even if you go down further
brazil people from
even if you go to you know you go to the
uh the caribbean patagonian or do you
say caribbean i i don't know
i say caribbean well cubans the point is
if they're not mexican they're
surprisingly more conservative they
don't like being lumped in with illegal
immigrants
so i think that democrats have really
misgauged them they really have
democrats whole plan has been to go
after the
latino vote we've seen that in every
primary we've seen it every presidential
election so far and in the new numbers
from florida donald trump is doing
very well he's doing better than yes he
is comparatively he's beating
he's beating biting and also in arizona
another place where that's going to
matter a lot he's up now trump is up by
a point in arizona when he's been down
for a while i thought he might lose
arizona i think it's 46 45
the margin of error is still i think
three or two and a half to three and a
half somewhere in there so it's still
within the margin of error but it's a
huge shift like you're seeing
this movement when they're like playing
this morning
this morning one poll okay i've seen the
road abc it was the abc news oh and
that's a really bad poll but it was
likely voters and not just registered
voters right
the people that are likely to go out
both of those the numbers i gave you
from florida and arizona abc
this morning yeah so i don't see a world
in which donald trump does not win
arizona and florida
uh it'll be close i think if he loses if
he loses for example like texas and
missouri which rcp has toss-ups
i can't see a world in which donald
trump loses texas or missouri and
doesn't lose
every single step yeah i mean we should
be the last to go
if you're in that world you're you're i
mean there's not gonna be any states i
mean they're right yeah
like exactly but you know i think what
it is is that again the
the backfiring of the progressive left
is that you're viewing people in blocks
based on their skin color ethnicity and
black block
yeah right or you're you know for
example you've got uh
vice president biden saying oh well
there's not a not as much diversity in
the black community as there is
uh the different types they're all black
which is
that he knows there are differing voting
blocs within the latino community right
but
they're all again they're just saying
it's just latino latino latino all we're
going to hit is immigration immigration
immigration right but not realizing that
there are there's a strong contingent of
religious conservative
voters who are looking for a reason to
vote
conservatives right if they can if
there's any way they can
or they don't think that vice president
biden is going to see them other than a
check box
to get to the election they're not going
to do it and that's something that
they're just continually ignoring while
they
say they're going for the latino vote
they're not actually working towards
addressing the issues in those
communities well they are for illegal
immigrants by the way hit the
notification bell if you're subscribed
on youtube because uh subscriptions
don't mean a whole lot
we do this show monday through thursday
every morning live and we take your chat
10 a.m eastern
next week we have the big stream on
tuesday night the theme by the way is
old school boxing so send in your
costumes
nice and next week is it we have a break
on wednesday thursday because we are
going to be in lansing at the state
capitol
uh major scoop to unveil down there and
uh we're actually going to be
encouraging you to take part in activism
because governor whitmer i've got your
number sweetheart so that's going to be
friday is that october second or third
friday october
2nd october 2nd uh i think it's at noon
at noon
you got the numbers from her i got the
num i don't have the numbers yet but see
now you're foreshadowing
yeah it's all the old people she killed
that she hasn't really revealed remember
so governor whitmer we're coming
we got a request for you sweetheart and
it's not it's not to lower your boat
over there in charlevoix and then
saturday's the big fight right
saturday the fight with chris chris and
you've got a full pack
i've bit off more than i can chew all
right in the world of of uh uh of uh i
was about to say de blasio bloomberg
yeah it was close to the scene i didn't
know you slept with people like
bloomberg
uh i know but uh
he would have uh people like kyle
rittenhouse and
people like james gardner who the
storyboard those people would be locked
up or dead which is actually what we
have
right and uh people like skurlock could
void uh could vote people like
uh uh jacob blake could vote so people
who commit violent felonies can vote and
people who defend themselves lose their
right to
uh live freely in the united states of
america um
look cnn let's go to them really quickly
nothing on hunter biden
to support nothing on hunter biden they
had like a new slash go across to all
the reporters do not say the name hunter
or buddy
we cannot get to the vice currently
running for president's son
uh spending money from foreign think
about just the money that hunter biden
took
from the former mayor of moscow's wife
to spend on hookers is more than russia
paid in all of their facebook hats ever
right and if it's not
and if anything is breaking news it is
not this at least
have it up there and say this is the
worst thing that the republicans have
ever done breaking news they lied about
hunter biden they're not even doing that
because they can't they're like covid
gives you the sniffles
breaking news guys oh god hunter don't
say hunter bye go coven
the worst thing this republican will
ever do is stick a gun in my mouth if
this news cycle doesn't change here
don't do it just don't just say his name
hunter biden
[Laughter]
i can't it stings
burns i just hate all the things so jake
gardner you guys may have remembered
this
uh sorry it wasn't oklahoma it was omaha
remember the protests they were in omaha
and
uh a bar owner no i was the one who
queued up jake uh
gardner yeah jake gardner was a bar
owner and it was a james scurlock was
the guy who attacked
him so gardner shot skurlock in
self-defense
and uh let's go really quickly here um
you can just run it as b-roll or secure
or is it is it a clip i think it's a
clip
of volume yeah okay you know what you
can uh yeah here's the security footage
in case you had forgotten let's roll
this really quickly um
of yeah you can see garner is mounted by
a guy
right he fires a warning shot that guy
gets up and leaves he tries to get up
and that scurlock who jumps in tackles
him and continues punching him in the
head
right you see this here and then he
finally ends up shooting
skurlock so this was outside of a bar in
case people don't remember this
now we can bring up the volume because
it was his attorney to get the gun away
from him
even if they're difficult decisions even
if they might be unpopular decisions
but again it's based on what the
evidence is and what the law is and
that's what i hope people understand
here
so that was the county attorney don
quinn right we covered this we thought
it was kind of the end of it where he
said uh he wouldn't file charges because
this was
truly justified shooting again let's
keep in mind it wasn't just uh
a war of words and then they start
shooting right it was a guy who got on
top of him i don't know the first guy
bang bang bang punching him trying to
try to pound his head into concrete
uh and then trying to take his gun
gardner
fired a warning shot you can clearly see
nothing that guy gets up runs away
and so he's getting up the second time
then another guy tackles him
starts behind into the concrete yeah and
he shot him and the county attorney said
all right this is clear justified
self-defense but then activists of
course went
nuts because they get the stories wrong
always
and the attorney crumbled and turned the
case over to a grand jury
who um found him uh guilty with four
felonies including manslaughter so if he
had been convicted gardner would face 95
years in prison
uh and he killed himself so gardner
committed suicide because he
talked about a guy who defends himself
from not one but
two savage beatings and already fired a
warning shot
uh is then charged with felonies
do this is a question to you if this
isn't justified
uh use of your second amendment rights
what does it have to be someone have
having already entered your gun safe
in your home yeah yeah these are two
people who were beating his head
into the concrete with no one here's
something else people don't think
people were around yeah none of them
helped because guess what
if he'd have fought somebody off with
his hands i don't care if he's the ufc
heavyweight champion in the world
there's another guy lining right up and
they're all going to jump on you
he he would have been at least beaten
into the icu beaten into a
into a coma at best at worst would have
been torn apart
like by a pack of wolves yeah again they
were trying to take his gun yeah
they were going to the ground and it's
not just that there were two guys that
he
fired the warning shots i think he
actually fired two warning shots in that
moment he had an opportunity to shoot
them and chose not to right they get up
and go away he starts to get up back
turn a guy comes not only is punching
him he's actually choking him with his
right arm
right and so he finally at some point is
i i either
i'm about to die yeah or i'm going to
have to shoot this guy and shoots the
guy in i think the clavicle right here
through the neck something like that
from
from right here right and what else is
he supposed to do i think maybe wait
until you die and then use your gun
what do you think there is that how they
post i mean you saw the the flying leap
that the guy took on
his back i mean there was no question in
that moment and that was the second guy
right and that's second guy right that's
absurd
that's the second beating the third guy
there were two guys initially
can't keep track of all the beatings
that are happening here uh
there's no question that when you know
when when you had that a moment in the
announcement that there
that there was just self-defense
involved that seemed like the right
decision
it seemed that it's supported by the
evidence by the witnesses by the camera
uh by the camera footage and then you
see what is a very clearly the the
bullying
and ignoring of evidence that then
caused
the government to crumble and move
forward to bring these charges and it's
a tragedy because it's essentially
folks not only saying you already have
the bad actors who are saying
we don't care what the facts are if you
shot someone who's on our side
right end game this person deserves to
burn right and again not just even well
he committed the crime of defending
himself while white
yes well yeah that's obviously what
that's really really really really
really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really really really really what we're
using a gun because apparently everyone
who has a gun is a racist
and you know i mean those kinds of well
unless you're that [ __ ] in austin
texas and you aim it in a car at an uber
right right but that guy was justified
well i mean it's just it's
listen and i know we always have to be
careful because we don't have all the
information but come on
if not this what this is where when
people say no one's coming for your guns
no one's coming for your second
amendment rights uh i would say that's
coming for second amendment rights
if you punish somebody who was being
beaten
twice by three different people and
fired warning shots
listen you're telling people they don't
have the right to defend themselves yeah
absolutely you're basically faced with a
choice right now in america
where if you get attacked by a group of
people you you can either be
killed potentially right or you can
defend yourself and then have your life
completely ruined either by going to
jail because they charge you falsely
with a crime when you defend yourself or
people are just going to show up at your
house forever go to your job forever and
make sure you never earn a dime again
and push you into a situation where you
think suicide is the best way out
honestly
you know people talk about suicide being
a coward if if i'm him
and i'm charged right with 95 years in
prison at this point
and i'm the white guy who shot a black
guy and maybe i know i'm going to the
wrong prison where they're not going to
be treating me very well yeah
i understand it i understand it your
life is ruined and not only that
and i want to talk about it more sort of
talk but punting it to a grand jury and
how that works behind the paper
for people who are mug club members lot
of credit dot com slash mug club we
can't get into all the nerdy legalese
but
bill is an actual practicing litigator
uh so i want to get his insight on that
but here's something else they're trying
to ruin the guy's name
after he's dead yeah right so keep in
mind with george floyd with jacob blake
with prude
they lied and saying well these are
people these were effectively saints no
one is perfect and no one is all bad
however this guy had not committed
anything even close to the you know
multiple sexual assaults or child rape
like rosenbaum
so we need to be really clear they're
bad apples people are imperfect but you
know when you have four
five six seven violent felonies on your
record versus none you think that'd be
taken into context
the state senator megan hell uh megan
hunt
hell was a good word megan hunt yeah
change that there for omaha's district 8
said
uh the indictment of this is after the
indictment of jake gardner would never
have happened without the community
the people the mob the pitchfork who
stood up for justice and demanded action
from city officials
jake gardner is gone oh because he
committed suicide uh but the white
supremacist attitudes that emboldened
him
are still with us today wow let's be
clear there is zero evidence that he's a
white supremacist
they've said after reviewing private
evidence we've concluded this okay
just just give me a taste like hunter
biden with a little bit of that thimble
of coke just just give me a taste of the
evidence of him being a white
supremacist if you have any just
show us anything a swastika burning
cross him having joined the wrong
message board
anything yeah and she's gloating over
his corpse right
he's gone well and by the way uh last
time i checked
just let's assume being a white
supremacist supremacist and not doing
anything is not grounds for getting your
butt kicked and beaten
into a coma or killed no last time i
checked
yeah you had the right to be an idiot in
this country it's your actions that we
basically even
let's say the guy were a white sup was a
white supremacist and he walked up and
he said
you're you're black i think you're dumb
i don't know how white supremacists
probably talk black people are stinky
but you know maybe you did something
like that
you still don't have the right to beat
the hell out of him my point is even if
he's a racist son of a [ __ ]
and i've known a couple of them i met
one at bob evans once that's the first
time i heard someone use the
word ironically i've told the story i
was like oh my god you're the person
they're talking
you exist you're a unicorn but how do i
know that he wasn't that because there's
a long history of evidence let me show
you this guy so gardner was a marine
okay
iraq war veteran who did help on the
trump campaign but he was peaceful he
was actually supportive of the peaceful
protest the the [ __ ] march remember we
forgot about that because it went from
black victims to female victims to black
victims again even though some of these
criminals who happen to be black have
victimized women by repeatedly sexually
assaulting them we ignore them because
it's an election year we need to raise
money for black lives matter
he actually supported the [ __ ] march in
the peaceful protest we have a video
of the man in question this white
supremacist fascist here he was
what do you think about what's going on
here today with the women's march uh you
know these people just want to be heard
and it's it's a very appropriate venue a
very appropriate weekend with all eyes
on them so i mean
it is what it is it's it's kind of crazy
being in the belly of the beast here
with my
my trump gear and my make america great
vest on my dog you know and uh
all the dirty looks everybody loves the
dog until they read the vest you know
but you know everybody just wants to be
heard and so
that's what they're doing they're not
being violent there's not there's not
even that issue with this group
before you say it it's not a crime to
look like yanni okay so he didn't
deserve to die and if he's a he's a
white supremacist he
sucks at it yeah he's really bad i'm a
skin head yeah exactly and
by the way i think what you said there
and what we just saw that's why she he
was he was associated with trump that's
why he's a racist
but think about this for a second even
though we went out there and we mocked
the [ __ ] the [ __ ] hat march right of
course
they interviewed him yeah i interviewed
wendy davis as the transgender
only got the interview because i was
stephanie a transgender she couldn't say
no
even after my wig flew off that's
hilarious that being said i always
thought hey this is kind of
inappropriate
to protest at the state capitol and show
your breasts and have giant paper mache
vaginas
i was like i don't really think this is
really appropriate when kids are here
but we never ever you never heard us say
they don't have the right to protest
ever you never heard us say oh we need
to shut this down that is very different
from people committing assault from
people burning down police precincts
from people taking over swaths of towns
from people destroying cities
and economies from people shooting cops
from people committing two billion
dollars in damages
over a thousand officer casualties over
30 people dead at these protests okay
that's very different i am just like
gardner
in this scenario and that yeah i think
that they're
wrong the [ __ ] hat marge i thought it
was silly was based on a lie remember
the 77 cents on the dollar
but i don't think the ideas stand up to
scrutiny so i support their right to
protest
i do not support your right to riot and
this guy was caught in the middle of it
where three people assaulted him over
the course of two
savage beatings he fired two warning
shots
it was well known including from the
from the community attorney saying okay
we're not going to file charges with
self-defense
it took the pitchfork mob the pitchfork
and torch mob who by the way
have knighted floyd multiple-time felon
yeah
uh jacob like multiply multiple times
sexual assault a rosenbaum who just
happened to be shot by a written house
multiple time child rapist why don't
they always pick the worst
guy and now this guy ended up killing
him
yeah so it is an absolute travesty of
justice and we're going to continue
actually uh here uh for mug club only
talking about these jurisdictions where
bill barr has said
no moss no mo that's not roberto duran
that's bill barr he's bilingual
uh youtube thank you but really we love
the mug club folks more so you can uh
you can
go piss up